thought experiment about this called
quantum suicide and immortality have you
heard of it
okay so essentially what i'm wondering
is under the many worlds interpretation
do you not live forever
because if we define you as the
experiencing you
because by definition you can't
experience when you're dead
so why is it that you don't live forever
because there's no world where
where you get to live forever right like
okay let's say
um i'm gonna think about myself and all
of the
many superpositions i can go into from
this point
um so there's many things that could
happen to me that that put me in
superposition
uh maybe like something to do that with
weather is a quantum fluctuation i don't
know how that could happen but like
let's just say
you know it might rain tomorrow because
of quantum mechanics or it might not
so there'll be a version of me that
experiences the rain and one that
doesn't
but in both of those worlds i will die
eventually like there's no
immortality there and like in every
sort of possible world um that is like
dependent on a quantum
fluctuation uh like i can't see
any of those worlds where i become a
model is there not a world where
your dna is constantly repaired and the
earth and the sun doesn't
burn out and so on so you do live
forever
so the laws of physics have to be obeyed
in every one of these
universes um so the sun will inevitably
burn out
um just there unless like there is
i i mean i can't see it but like unless
there's some
way for it to not happen quantum
mechanically
but i don't think so um so the sun will
burn out in every one of those universes
um my dna repairing is not down to
quantum fluctuations
it's down to other um other factors
which like
couldn't go both ways and so um
like that that's also not a path to
mortality and how about this okay
methune is
instantly recreated you're now 18
and it's like perfect health you're
probably already in perfect health but
you're now 18.
and there's a is there not a small small
small chance of that
occurring right now just a poof version
of methune that breaks the laws of
physics somehow
so the way that i'm imagining this is
that there's a continuum of where the
electron can be
and then that is for every single
electron in your body and then
that is also for every single proton in
your body and so on and so so you just
transport yourself
yeah so i think that is a
that this is like no different from um
you know if i like because anything
could uh sort of spontaneously
um come into being right like because
because of like
very freak quantum um uh fluctuations
but like let's say that you know um
you're sitting here
and then like on the other side of the
universe
uh the the eiffel tower just like
materializes
on some other random planet right um
now it's it's a sort of philosophical
question
whether you count that as the eiffel
tower is it the same thing
right um and so like if a version of me
just materializes randomly
somewhere else in the galaxy uh is is
that
is that me um well i wouldn't experience
it being me because i
i only have my continuous experience
from this body
um so that that person if if
if they materialize with all my memories
of course will think of themselves as me
but i would think of them as
as a person distinct from me um and
there's no sort of
um contradiction there and also it
doesn't grant me myself
any immortality even if uh like this
keeps happening
do you think of yourself as the same
person when you wake up
because you're going yeah so this is it
yeah um
so this is like all you know like deep
philosophical questions have been
debated for a long time but
yes i do think of myself as the same
person when i wake up and
something to do with the continuity of
experience or
something about being able to um like
uh remember even if it's inaccurately
what it was like to be that person
before
um like makes me feel like the same
person whereas
if there's another version of me even if
they have the same memories as me
and they themselves therefore think that
of themselves as me like they
both of us imagine out like past smith
as their past
and that is 100 accurate i would not
would not associate with that person
because that person is not sharing any
experiences with me